[Musique]
les forces séparatistes qu'ils ont dit
d'évacuer immédiatement parce que les
crèmes prépare une agression majeur du
tas de sauna et on entend les tirs
depuis deux jours la russie leur
première 3 et un peu d'argent dès leur
arrivée mais ce matin est si le chaos
tout l'or du monde ne pourrait consoler
valentina qui fond en larmes quand on
lui demande où son mari
beaucoup de familles si les maris
ont été appelés à la mobilisation
générale donc s'il ya une guerre c'est
pour se battre
beaucoup d'enquêtés sur des parpaings
plus les jours passent plus est
impossible de se détacher de
l'atmosphère militaire qui règne ici et
pendant que la communauté internationale
regarde attend nerveuse et ben en
ukraine le gouvernement a décidé qu'il
fallait maintenant se préparer au pire
se préparer ou pire c'est ce dont a
témoigné tamara alter ego dans ses
nombreux reportages depuis plusieurs
semaines bien sûr vous l'a suivi depuis
quelques mois ce coup il ya quatre ans
mais ces dernières semaines vous êtes
accroché à ses reportages vous vous êtes
même inquiété pour elle et puis chez
vous et vous l'avez admirer de jour en
jour sont aux anges elle est de passage
à montréal pendant la chandeleur se voir
sur notre plateau tamara intéresse qu
bonsoir enfin répondantes à moscou
depuis quatre ans et on va commenter ces
images là parce que c'était la
préparation de la guerre puis pendant
que vous allez me répondre vous regardez
aussi les chars d'assaut vous avez
découvert sur sur la route oui je pense
qu'on a commencé à comprendre l'équipe
de moscou en tout cas que c'était c'est
a toujours été sérieux il y avait des
milliers troubles depuis des semaines à
la frontière de l'ukraine mais autour du
16 février dur byden dit non seulement
l'attaqué et éminente elle est à 100%
sûr on sait pas encore quelle sera
l'échelle et il y avait toujours ses
images satellites on voyait des chats on
savait pas où il était c'est hélène ce
qu'ils disaient non ccpo sérieux donc on
est allé à belgorod et on ne roulait des
heures et des heures en campagne ce une
frontière qui team ans jusqu'à ce qu'un
villageois nous disent vous voulez les
voir suivez moi et on est tombé sur une
colonne mais qui faisaient des centaines
de mètres c'est la première fois que
j'ai vu le fameux z qui était sûr feront
d un des blindés
et c'est là c'est pas qu'on a compris
l'ampleur de la menace mais c'est là
qu'on l'a incarnée oui c'est une chose
de voir les images satellites d'entendre
les discours politiques d'un côté comme
de l'autre mais de voir et de parler aux
résidents de ce qu'ils vivaient en temps
réel avait peur des résidents y résident
il croyait pas on leur disait une banque
une thérapie l'administration on a
stationné d'aider des chars d'assaut
devant chez moi devant mon commerce qu
est ce que c est un exercice militaire
vous inquiétez pas puis à force de les
voir se préparer les soldes parle pas on
n'avait pas le droit de les filmer dans
les films en cachette il y avait un
mystère qui planait autour de leur
activité et plus les jours passent et on
est resté dans la région de rostov
belgorod plus c'était plus difficile
était plus difficile de les trous et on
les voyait sur les routes on les voyait
à la gare on les voyait devant le
dépanneur
c'est impressionnant parce que j'imagine
que tout se faisait tout en secret et
toi et donc de les avoir découverts ils
vous ont pas du tout importuner à ce
moment là faisant ses fers y avait plus
de clients avait plus de secrets hiver
et je pense que le jour où on a vu des
camions citernes remplis d'essence se
diriger vers la frontière ukrainienne en
tout cas en parlant des experts mille
tonnes de cesser le ravitaillement
évidemment on a vu aussi des camions
transportés l'équipement nécessaire pour
établir des hôpitaux de fortune
ça devenait très vrai et je pense qu'on
était et quand poutine un reconnu
l'autonomie des deux territoires de
lougansk et de donetsk on a compris
qu'ils allaient avoir une invasion ou
une incursion quelconque moi
personnellement je les voyais s'arrêter
à mario paul ce qui était déjà une image
maïmouna inimaginable le soir du 24
quand vladimir poutine a fait son
discours
j'étais en ont d'abord avec vous plus
près avec marie-eve bédard et l'état à
kiev et on entendait les premières
frappes sur kiev très symbolique
il ya eu un avant et un après oui tout
de change et vous êtes habitué sur le
terrain mais vous avez vécu plusieurs
moments forts on vend revivent avec vous
si vous voulez bien parce que vous êtes
c'est sur le front et c'est tout le
dilemme de déchirement de cette guerre
de ces peuples frères
une paire complètement une personne en
russie l'autre en ukraine on vous écoute
dans dans un court extrait de ce
reportage
des chars circulent et des convois de
soldats et les gens attendent pour
rentrer à la maison et on vient de
parler à vallières qui nous a dit que sa
soeur etc qui vous explique l'absurdité
de cette invasion
valia habite du côté russe à sept
kilomètres de la frontière à la temps
pour rentrer chez elle sa soeur habite
attractive se parlent au téléphone
aujourd'hui ça seraient cachées dans le
sous sol parce que des bombardements
elle est inquiète les terroriser elle
entend ces bombardements parce qu'on est
à seulement 50 km de cette ville qui est
bombardé et c'est la réalité de ces
villes frontalières quand on dit qu'on
mène la guerre aux ukrainiens il ya
beaucoup de douleur ici c'est les
familles c'est les cousins qui habite de
l'autre côté maintenant ça sert juste à
côté elle sait que l'armée russe qui a
accaparé son secteur son village est en
train de bombarder la ville de sa soeur
en face à devoir de vie ces déchirements
et c'est des moments privilégiés pour
expliquer aux gens l'absurdité de ce
conflit la guerre c'est toujours absurde
c'est toujours désolant mais seule celle
là en particulier étant donné l'histoire
de la russie l'histoire de l'ukraine
la majorité des russes que je connais
ont des racines ukrainienne donc oui
c'est un exemple et ça à belgorod c'est
exactement là où on était trois semaines
plus tôt où on voyait les chars se
déployer ça finit par devenir un centre
d'opérations très important à partir
d'où l'on tire des missiles
aussi sur karkhiv notamment sur kim et
surtout surtout et et nous on dit
j'étais au front moi j'ai jamais été en
danger physique vous savez des fois
après des longues journées je parle avec
marie-eve on s'écrivait l'était elle
vivait un danger réel à la crème pour
son intégrité
personnelle physique nous c'était plus
le silence on va en parler la répression
et la censure c'est d'essayer d'informer
mais avec une menace constante est-ce
que c'était difficile de faire parler
les russes ossètes ou vaya où les
hôtesses que les gens vous exprimer
certaines inquiétudes vous fierté dans
les yeux les deux mois j'avais la ferme
impression
pour avoir fait du terrain beaucoup
beaucoup de terrain qui avait peu de
soutien pour ce genre de guerre qu'on
n'a pas le droit d'appeler une guerre
comme crème en russie et je sentais
qu'il y avait une tolérance pour une
incursion comme on l'appelait vers le
dôme basse mais pas plus loin sa vie la
crimée a été prise sans un sans un coup
de feu part vladimir poutine dont il ya
beaucoup il y avait il y avait un peu
cette illusion chez les russes qu'on
pouvait en faire autant avec les
territoires de lougansk de donetsk et
vous avez quitté moscou pour nous et
dans quelles circonstances pas quel
moment on a parlé de cette loi
répressives à l'endroit des journalistes
de sud qui exprime quelque chose de
contraire vos messages et vous avez fait
un reportage qui illustre bien la les
entraves qu'on vous met à chaque jour
donc pour l'exercice de votre merci
c'est devenu si on écoute ce court
extrait aussi
les gens sortent manifester mais c'est
complètement interdit les avons arrêtés
sous nos yeux monter dans des autobus ça
fait parti d'un environnement de censure
qui est à son mieux à son comble plus
depuis ce matin
de cliquer pas même été chassés des
nommés est possible de filmer et ce y
compris les médias qui diffusent qui est
jugée de la désinformation par le
kremlin s'expose désormais à une peine
qui peut aller jusqu'à 15 ans de prison
donc les russes subissent cette
répression la maison vous comme
journaliste ou si vous subissez des
pressions jamais vu jamais vécu depuis
vous êtes en russie mais mes collègues
d'avant absolument j'ai couvert beaucoup
de manifestations pro navale les
antilles vladimir poutine au fil des
quatre ans où je suis j'étais à moscou
jamais on s'en est pris à la presse on
s'en prend tant pop ça arrive qu'on tape
sur la presse mais c'est jamais le
interdit d'être là pour couvrir
l'événement c'est la première fois qu'on
me dit
dégage dégage et avec cette épée de nous
du possible arrestation et peines
d'emprisonnement ça s'est concrétisé le
lendemain et dans cette manifestation
l'oeil avait il y avait des gens
probablement payé entre ces peaux
claires mais qui nous suivait et chaque
fois qu'on essaie de tourner au
téléphone pour être discret nous
arracher le téléphone s'impose est
physiquement devant nous on prend des
mesures extraordinaires pour empêcher
les journalistes de faire leur travail
et pas toujours les journalistes
étrangers les journalistes indépendants
ouais ben aviez vous l'impression que
les journalistes étrangers étaient plus
ou moins réussis par rapport à ces
journalistes indépendants qui ont été
carrément fermée par les ordures de
sites fermés mais carrément fermé par
les autorités russes toujours dit plus
facile d'être journaliste étranger parce
qu'on informe pas les russes on n'a pas
un pouvoir d'influencé sur les russes
nous en informe les canadiens dans mon
cas là ça a été très clair le lendemain
quand la loi était adoptée la loi de
censure qui menaçait de 15 ans de prison
de quatre de colonies de travail que ça
concernait autant les médias étrangers
que les médias locaux il fallait prendre
une décision en mari est ce qu'on peut
continuer à faire notre travail en
russie avec les normes et les standards
que nous avons comme média indépendant
chez qu'il ya des gens qui nous écrit
pour n'est pas des médias indépendants
font les médias d'être heureux soucis ce
débat les trolls rustre le canadien ce
climat là n'existent plus j'étais
pendant pendant quatre ans j'ai pu les
gens sont étonnés quand je leur dis
faire mon travail avec une grande
liberté parce que quand de l'écrin
papier sur le web de radio-canada pas de
premier au moment de votre départ
rassurer vos enfants sur ce qui l'attend
dès que vous parlez du privilège de
l'honneur que vous alliez dans ce pays
le pm vous vous décrivez moscou comme
une ville qui ne dort pas qui
en fait comme si cela n'existait pas
qu'il ya beaucoup de joie de vivre à
moscou voulait une capitale européenne -
et puis avez vous l'impression qu'avec
toutes ces sanctions dans ce qu'on
apprenait aujourd'hui lors que l'on
appelle les appels d'entreprises
françaises a quitté des milliers
d'emplois
avez vous l'impression que toutes ces
sanctions qu'on a un pause va vraiment
affecter la vie de ces gens là que vous
avez couvert côtoyé puis qui vont bien
on recentre qu'est-ce qu'ils vont
ressentir de l'humain il ya en ce moment
il ya un mouvement de panique je parle
souvent tous les jours à mes amis en
russie il manque de sucre il manque
d'orge manque de services sanitaires de
lait des produits qui dot on ne manque
pas en stock mais les gens achètent par
panique parce que de l'inflation les
prix ont augmenté on a peur d'avoir des
pénuries donc yeux ça ça ça fait
beaucoup quand on veut chez starbucks
starbucks n'est qu'on va acheter un café
on nous dit le secret caché parce que
les gens les mettre dans secret dont on
est rendu à faire des achats par panique
les vraies conséquences apparaître privé
de mcdo apparaître privé bon de toutes
les chaînes américaines auxquelles la
jeunesse qui n'a jamais connu rien
d'autre que les luxe qui viennent de
l'étranger c'est l'ex dental à
l'occidentale mais de la france de
l'europe
à part ça il ya une déprime
les conséquences réelles les roubles le
rouble les gens se précipitent des
machines qui manquent de roubles
c'est ce qui s'en vient qui fait part et
celle isolement de la russie j'ai dit en
ouverture que vous étiez sorti
temporairement j'imagine que vous
nourrissez le plus grand désir le plus
grand rêve d'y retourner
non non on a un bureau à moscou j'ai mon
appartement ma fille passé la moitié de
sa vie à moscou on s'est attaché
beaucoup à ce prix là c'est sûr que
partirai mais on était juste un départ
réputé comme un précipité hauteur on
n'était pas obligé d'annoncer qu on
suspendait les activités il fallait le
faire parce que les gens avaient une
atteinte par rapport à la couverture en
russie les bureaux fonctionnent toujours
on y retourne rock quand les conditions
de travail
seront assez approprié pour qu'on puisse
assurer la sécurité de nos employés ça
c'est la barre oui bah écoutez la barre
pour tout ce que vous avez vous désirez
la baule plus le plus vite possible mais
quand c'est votre merveilleuse
couverture voix en complicité avec
marie-eve alors bien ce merci on est
content d'avoir reçu sur le plateau et
années pour voir nos émissions en entier
rendez vous sur la chaîne ici et redit
[Musique]
on